teachers in England and astonishing a
hundred and twenty one thousand two
hundred and fifty three members yes for
strike action twelve thousand eight
hundred and eleven but we know it was a
majority over 90 percent
90.44 voted for strike with a threshold
busting turnout of 53.27 it's an amazing
result
teachers in Wales even stronger in a
smaller constituency but a majority over
92 percent a turnout over 58 again
busting through the government's
thresholds we regret to see on support
staff in England although 15
405 voted yester strike and only 2 900
voted no a very big majority of 84 but
because of the government's unfair
undemocratic thresholds the the majority
the turnout in that was 46 and that's
not enough for us to call Legal strike
action however support staff in Wales
again beat the thresholds with the
Turner of 51.3 percent a majority of
88.26 these ballot results are amazing
the England teacher ballot results alone
is the biggest ballot result of any
Union in recent times
certainly since this operatic threshold
was introduced in 2017 2016. we have cut
with our England and Wales ballots
together spanning 23 400 schools our
teacher members England and Wales our
support staff members in Wales have
voted in enough numbers to beat both of
the government's thresholds for
industrial action that have been imposed
on teachers and other essential public
service over of all teacher members of
the Union voted by post when there was
significant disruption to The Postal
Service the government needs to listen
these are Big votes for strike action
they really are 90 of our members voting
voted yes and that shows the government
something really important it shows the
government that the Neu members will not
stand by
and see the Education Service they work
so hard for and they care for so much be
sacrificed because teachers and support
staff are being driven from the
profession they love because of a toxic
mix of low pay and excessive workload
neither should the support of the South
figures in England give the government
any cheer the hard facts cannot be
ignored children are losing out because
there aren't enough teachers and support
staff
parents and grandparents hear their
children and grandchildren talking about
new teachers in the middle of the school
year of their favorite teachers leaving
of teachers not being available in the
subject that they are learning
parents of children with special
educational needs know that support
staff
that the support staff their children
rely on to access learning are leaving
schools to work in supermarkets because
they can be paid more there
public servants are suffering the
longest period of pay suppression since
the Napoleonic Wars
a teacher who started work in 2010 and
made normal progress up the pay scale
has lost over 64 000 pounds in cash
terms support staff have lost 27 of
their pay in real terms since 2010 and
that's why teacher recruitment is in
crisis with a 23 fall in applications
this year that's why teacher retention
is in crisis with 40 percent of teachers
leaving within 10 years of qualification
with one in eight leaving within two
years of qualification
that's why secondary class sizes are now
the highest that they have ever been
it's why primary plus sizes are the
highest they've been since 2000 and
these are not my words these are the
words of Amanda Spielman who I don't
normally quote with approval
Amanda spielmann the Chief Inspector of
ofsted has written in her latest ofsted
annual report but remember 20 to two
that there's a Workforce crisis in our
schools
the school leaders report that
recruiting and retaining teachers and
support staff is their biggest challenge
in work and that children and young
people are there in the brunt of that
crisis without access to the teachers
and support they need in order to get
the education they are entitled to
so we've got some shout outs and thanks
to everybody for popping some messages
on there and one from Jenny Cooper who
says a massive well done to all of our
reps and I looked absolutely second that
as well and message from Julie saying
great news thanks to everybody
and also brilliant news from Dion and
Tim says excellent news all School
workers worked and deserve a decent
properly funded pay rise
Michaela is saying excellent result
absolutely agree very good result but
very hard work from everybody who's been
involved in it and Dale as a trainee
teacher I'm with everyone who was going
on strike the Tories are destroying
everything and then just one final shout
out as well which I think I absolutely
fully agree with fantastic results and
proud to be part of Neu
you know Mary's just given you a quote
from Amanda Spielman but just in the
last week we have seen studies from The
Institute of fiscal studies there he was
at an event today with the national fun
for uh for Education research all
confirming the arguments that we're
making about why there is a shortage of
teachers all of them saying there is
going to have to be a correctional
teacher pay but we know it's the reality
the daily stress of working in an
underfunded school with exhausted staff
receiving poor pay which has led Neu
members to vote Yes for strike action we
know that you haven't taken this
decision lightly you want to be in your
classrooms teaching and supporting
children and young people the decision
to strike for all of us is a last resort
so we do intend to make this work our
Aim so uh we were promised that we'd
hear the results of those ballots uh
dead on the dots of five o'clock and uh
so it came to Pass the Joint General
secretaries of the National Education
Union there Kevin Courtney and Mary
boosted joined by the national president
uh Louise Atkinson teachers in England
and Wales are set to go on strike in
February and March after members of the
Union that voted in favor of action in
their ongoing dispute over pay they say
that the ballot is a result of failure
by the Secretary of State in England and
the employees in Wales to ensure enough
money is available to pay a fully funded
increase in pay for teachers which at
least matches inflation and which begins
to restore lost pay well our chief